just gonna say would that be because you
said cheating would that be considered
cheating if they are both in an
agreement no no no no no no cheating I
would
I was hooking up behind the back what if
he was not mine involved if it's not
lying involved and you know what do you
like what do you mean okay so say that
I'm in a relationship and my dude's like
hey yo I'm going to hang out at my
friend's house and he tells me who the
friend is a girl but it doesn't give me
or
yeah it doesn't give me like the full
details of what's going to happen is
that would you consider that lying like
it doesn't get if like it doesn't give
you the full details and then ends up
hooking up with her I would say that's
cheating yeah
but like lying about going to her like
not saying that maybe his ex would be at
a party or something or like something
like that yeah do you oh do you think
that dancing on another guy as a girl is
cheating so like grinding really no it
depends on like your partner's culture
as well like for example when it's
Carnival for like um what they like
their culture like I feel like if you're
going with the guy say you're not of the
same culture I'm not talking about
cultural dances I'm talking about like
grinding like Anna got like a girl girl
oh is it the same thing oh okay okay
okay okay
yeah so for example say
um my partner is from the Caribbean
carnivals have come in August after that
I know you're gonna do like I mean I'm
Jamaican I see um yeah it's for me to
understand that though as well me as a
person even if I'm part of your culture
I'm gonna know that like you're gonna
know I'm gonna go do my thing as well
but it's not for them in your culture
like for them I don't speak on it maybe
you can speak on that but um it's not
like for them in their eyes it's not
cheating she knows it's not cheating
it's more like that's part of their
that's what they do okay but what's that
I'm not trying to do it under the guise
of like culture I'm talking like some
girls go to a bar that one has a
boyfriend and she's grinding and like
twerking on another guy it's problematic
yeah
I would say that it's it goes down to
what do they agree to in the
relationship because
a guy may not may not care like oh yo
yeah you can go dance on whoever yeah I
don't care about it because you come
home with me tonight but a girl may have
some may have a problem if he if she
sees her man and another woman is
Dancing with him she may be like uh on
that I feel like a lot of couples don't
have that conversation and I think and
have conversations
and I think that a lot of guys don't
like I don't know I'll see girls like
with boyfriends like grinding on these
other guys I'm like did your boyfriend
be cool with that because I I don't know
what's going on I'm like if I'm in a
relationship and I go out and I'm with
my man I'm gonna dance with my man I'm
about to no no I'm talking about without
it you go out by yourself
so what if you go out of your girls I'm
not gonna dance on anybody really yeah
the key thing is she doesn't know a
carnival she doesn't know the UK the
carnival she doesn't know nothing Hill
Carnival and I think the key thing is
like basically the communication
relationship like we made us talk about
it from the start like oh like do you
consider this like cheating or like if I
were to do this like would it hurt your
feelings you know you just have to
clarify everything so that you know like
maybe not like from the start maybe like
before you go out with your girls you'll
be like okay like let's talk about this
just so like if you were to do something
then you know it wouldn't hurt their
feelings and then obviously if you knew
it would then you wouldn't do it but say
like if you don't know and you do it
because you don't consider that cheating
then I think that's a completely
different story I really do think
relationships are evolving yeah nowadays
I think relationships are not like our
grandparents generation they're just
evolve in and I think what what we can
see now is you know that um
you know that when something's changing
you have that
crazy time when things are changing and
it's like a bit crazy I think it's hard
to talk about is how to talk about it's
hard to do people don't know what's
going I think we're in that time and I
think I don't know give it another 50
years and the types of relationships
that will be
um that we think are crazy nowadays will
just be normal you know what I mean so I
think we're in that transition stage
yeah that's true it has been you know
I've seen a lot of what is it like
social media couples where it's like two
girls one man yeah I've seen that a long
time
but are they evolving or are they going
back to what they were that's the thing
that is interesting are they going back
to what they were huh way back in the
day yeah yeah like yeah
exactly and David had a gang of women
right right is it is it just going back
are we reverting back to who we are did
we did this point in time in history
just try to show us that as something
different and it's like ah you guys
can't do that go back to what you were
doing like is is that what is going on
here that's that's why I don't know now
we're more open to different things yeah
the world is evolving for example back
in the day like certain things a lot of
things were like more frowned upon like
there were more rules in in like in
place I think you see I don't think
about the explosive like people's
culture as well like back in the day it
was very important it was more harder
and more harder to be open to who you
are whereas now it's more open and you
can't be who you are but it's literally
all down to that communication as well I
just like it I don't like the way it's
evolved I think because I just grew up
in such like a old school traditional
yeah my because my my parents
my parents have like they've only slept
with each other and I think there's
no no
no no they started
says actually on the internet but I
swear I would bet like my my life I
would bet don't do that I would no I
would
yeah no don't vouch for any
sorry to cut you though um
um what I've noticed in
in my life is
people hide things very well 100 and
they know how to appear
a one-way
and something's going on I'm not saying
that your parents aren't that you know I
don't I'm not trying to speak parents at
all I'm not trying to do that but I'm
just saying
we don't know
but obviously you're gonna but that's
like how you're gonna view the world
like through your life experiences right
so you know fair enough but I was saying
like like I have nine siblings
and I just I think I think there's a
level like because they both like
maintained a level of Purity like before
they like met each other
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying my mom
my mom met him when she was 17. that's
what I'm saying like and they built a
multi-million dollar business they had
10 kids and like we live in it like I
feel like they want to adopt me
like you're like I would say you're one
of the lucky ones like yeah but I think
like more people necessarily the norm
that's not yeah you're not the norm
you're like but I feel like I feel like
their marriage is better because they
don't have all these like like connect
like you know you date someone for two
years and you marry someone else right
you still have that like connection with
the last person and like how many Exes
come back and like ruin marriage yeah
and all that like I feel like their
marriage was better yes because they
only have each other it and like I feel
like it worked better that way like when
women got married younger and like we
don't have to date for 10 years and get
our hearts broken like isn't it that's
amazing
yeah that's amazing yeah yeah right
there well and like my mom actually got
pregnant when she was 17 like by my dad
and they gave that kid up for adoption
and then like we reunited with him later
but like I don't know they're just like
we part of the family now yeah sort of
like not I mean he can't come to
everything he has his own stuff but yeah
like he comes to stuff right okay
yeah it's weird he's so similar to us
like even though we don't like you guys
oh yeah
I could show you there's a whole family
of redheads guys yeah but do you know
what's so funny we call them gingers
but even like because even if you do the
one-sided like open relationship like
guys still can get feelings for their
side chick like that that's still
opening your marriage up like I mean
guys leave their wives for their side
chick that's like yes even side chick
that thing said that their man's gonna
leave
it's not the norm but you're opening
your marriage up to like a possible like
why risk of that yeah yeah complete
breakage like so I just yeah I just
prefer the traditional I think it works
better than no I hate you yeah and I
think the way in which your parents done
everything is commendable if I'm I I
commend that yeah that's the